so the Big Bang Theory the Big Bang
Theory has the universe beginning
beginning at roughly 13.7 billion 13.7
we write this 13.7 billion years ago
that's when the entire universe was just
one tiny singularity there years ago we
take say the entire universe we talked
about all of all of space was this
little singularity 13.7 billion years
ago and then if we s right after that
moment if we move we're going to move
what's by art for for our type of
timescales a long amount of time but by
kind of a cosmological timescale just
really a fraction of a moment but if we
move ahead 300 and and actually the
actual number is about 380,000 years
this is our best estimate 380,000 years
forward so we're still pretty close to
the beginning especially if you saw that
correction I made on the last video that
still doesn't really change we're still
roughly 13.7 billion years ago because
this is this is only 0.3 million years
so if we rounded we're still right about
there but we're just a fraction of a
moment into the history of the universe
the universe has expanded expanded a
good bit relative to that singularity it
has some space but it's still this
unbelievably dense it's still this
unbelievably dense place on so super
dense instead of unbelievably it's super
dense it's this super dense place
especially relative to the universe that
we have today but the super dense
universe we have all of these things we
have enough space for actual a hydrogen
plasma to form I won't even call it
stable stable hydrogen atoms because
they're still just bumping into each
other it's just a very dense place and
it's white-hot I mean it's infinitely
energetic at the Big Bang but we're
still so dense things are still bumping
into each other and vibrating with it's
such high energies that this just this
hot white-hot haze so let me call it
white white hot haze
Heys of hydrogen plasma hydrogen
hydrogen plasma we're still on
cosmological scales not that far into
the life of the universe so that's what
the Big Bang would predict and all of
the models based on or most of the
models would based on the Big Bang at
around 380,000 years would have this
white-hot hydrogen plasma and then if we
fast forward just to kind of make sure
we understand where this story is going
if you fast forward 400 million years so
that's a lot more time this is obviously
not drawn to scale
then we've the all of space has expanded
enough to kind of give some breathing
room actual stable atoms form and while
we're getting to that 400 while we're
going through that 400 million years and
those hydrogen atoms start to condense
around each other slowly slowly slowly
400 million years once again is is a
pretty long in fact this is an
unfathomably long period of time 13.7
billion is really unfathomable but
already 400 million frankly even 380,000
years is an unfathomable amount of time
but after 400 million years you have the
first stars these hydrogen atoms start
to you know things start to get a little
bit sparse but then you have clumps of
things because of gravity and then those
clumps become denser and denser and
denser and eventually they get dense
enough and they can attract enough atoms
that you actually have you actually have
atomic fusion and you actually have
stars form and we'll do whole videos on
the fusion inside of stars and this is
I'll call this the first generation of
stars first generation because we know
you know I'm talking about
we just have hydrogen right over here
and we know now that we have this entire
periodic element periodic table of
elements of a periodic table of elements
you know just in our earth we have iron
and nickel and these very heavy heavy
atoms that are much heavier than the
hydrogen atom and these were actually
made in this first generation or maybe
in the first and second generation of
stars the hydrogen once it gets packed
closely enough with enough pressure it
fuses into helium and then and then the
helium is used as fuel for heavier and
heavier atoms and things get keep
getting fused and fused together inside
of the cores of these stars until they
run out of fuel and sometimes they will
just explode and that heavier those
heavier atoms will then spread into the
rest of space and many of those heavier
atoms have made it into our solar system
and our bodies and so if you go all the
way to the present a lot of then then we
start having these stars or not even
just these star second-generation stars
condensing into galaxies you have the
dust around them containing heavier
elements that can actually condense into
planets so that's way far off here but
that's not going to be the focus of this
video we'll talk more about that how
solar systems and planets are formed in
the future what I want to focus on is
this white hot one on this white hot
hydrogen plasma 380,000 years after the
Big Bang because if this is true if this
really did happen if we were to look at
any photons any electromagnetic waves
emitted from this period in time that's
taken a little under 13.7 13.7 billion -
380,000 years if it's taken that long to
get to us it was emitted at this period
of time
and so if it really was a white-hot haze
and if we were to really look at photons
that the electromagnetic waves that are
that are just reaching us from that
period of time it should be uniform it
should not be differentiated when you
look at things closer up to us it's very
differentiated you see pockets of
brightness and then you see pockets of
complete darkness we our current
universe seems very differentiated so in
order for the Big Bang or to be true we
should be able to observe this kind of
uniform background radiation all around
us and at first you know obviously with
your eye you don't see it if you look
into the night sky you just see big
pockets of of black where you don't see
any radiation coming from and even with
primitive telescopes we didn't see
anything until the late 1960s and the
late 1960s we were able to observe the
cosmic cosmic microwave microwave
background radiation background back
ground radiation and it's you know it's
fairly uniform no matter where we look
in the sky these photons that are coming
from
this time period are all uniform you
don't see pockets of intensity coming
from a star or a galaxy or a cluster of
galaxies it's just all uniform and not
only is it all uniform but most of the
energy is in the microwave in the
microwave segment of the electromagnetic
spectrum which is what something like
this white-hot haze of hydrogen plasma
would emit at the type of energies that
we're dealing with right over here so
just to make sure we understand what's
going on here so first of all this is a
big deal that this was discovered
because okay you believe in the Big Bang
you know everything is expanding from
everything at some point everything must
have had to be in this one singularity
but if that's case at some point you
would have had this white-hot haze if
you don't observe this cosmic microwave
background radiation then this is this
becomes hard to believe but if you do
then all of a sudden this becomes this
becomes a lot a lot more digestible so
actually the people who who actually
observe this who discovered this
actually got the Nobel Prize and and
they deserve to but I want you to I want
you to really internalize why it makes
sense that we get this uniform radiation
from every direction in the universe so
let's go back let's go back to this to
this depiction of the observable
universe that I showed many many videos
ago so this is us sitting here on earth
in our solar system inside of our local
group which is part of the Virgo
supercluster
right here in the center of our
observable universe and we're the center
of the observable universe not necess
most probably not the actual universe
but we're the center of the observable
universe because it's defined by what we
can observe is defined by universe a
uniform radius around us now let's think
about what's happening as we look
further and further out stuff over here
stuff over here that's roughly a billion
light years away that when we're
observing that stuff we're just seeing
the photons that were emitted from that
part of space 1 billion light years ago
so not only are we looking a billion
light years away in space we're also
looking a billion light weighs a billion
light years back in time so this will be
a slightly more primitive universe but
still or
of the universe but this will still be
differentiated so when you look at this
part of the universe you would have
these pockets of brightness and complete
pockets of darkness and then if you look
further back you're not only looking
further far away but you're also looking
further back in time because the photons
that were emitted from here and just
getting to us right now we're emitted if
I just look at this roughly about five
or six billion years ago so you're going
to look at it even a more primitive
universe and then if you go all the way
back over here to that stage where the
first stars form right over here though
that light that's reaching us just from
there that's from that very first stage
we're not only looking huge distance in
space and that space is expanding and we
learned a little bit about that in the
last video but we also saw we're also
going back a huge distance in time we're
looking at a very primitive universe if
we go all the way to the limits if we go
all the way to 13.7 billion light years
away that light and I have to be very
careful based on what we said in the
last video it's that distance is not
13.7 billion light years away anymore
that actual coordinate in space is now
46 billion light years away but those
photons that have traveled 13.7 billion
years they are showing us an image of
something that occurred 13.7 billion
years ago they're showing us they're
showing us that white-hot haze and I'll
write it in white they're showing us
that hydrogen plasma that's green
hydrogen they're showing us that
hydrogen plasma and so you should see
that in every direction as you look back
13.7 billion years because when you look
through 13.7 billion years all of this
all of this around the sphere of looking
around us that is all at the same
primitive stage in the history of the
universe and it and so it makes complete
sense that the photons emitted that are
just getting to us from this area out
here that they would all be uniform
because we hadn't differentiated at that
point into stars and planets and
galaxies and all of and superclusters
and all of the other things and so
that's why it one we are experiencing
this cosmic background radiation from
every direction and it's also a reason
why that's
a pretty strong piece of evidence that
the Big Bang occurred because we feel
pretty good that everywhere in the
universe about 13.7 billion years ago
was this white-hot haze of hydrogen
plasma let me be clear this coordinate
in the universe right now is actually
today right now and it's hard to think
about it it is differentiated it's just
the photons that we're getting from
there now actually left 13.7 billion
years ago when it was a white-hot plasma
if there's another so over the last 13.7
billion years this actually has
differentiated it's probably turned into
stars and galaxies and planets and maybe
civilizations have come out here and
maybe those civilizations are asking the
exact same questions that we're asking
and when they look at photons emitted
from our region of space they don't see
earth they don't see the Sun they don't
see the Milky Way they don't even see
they don't even see anything
differentiated they too from this region
of space will just see a white-hot haze
because they're seeing our region of
space as it was 13.7 billion years ago
anyway hopefully that you found that a
slightly illuminating